Hello. I'm Aimee Lou Wood.
I am Chinenye Ezeudu.
I'm George
from Sex Education.
And I'm going to help you
relax and let go
with some calming words
and music.
First of all,
make yourself comfortable,
and allow yourself to settle
into the space around you.
Prepare your body
to change gears,
like Otis and Eric
when they're riding
down the hill to school,
except much slower.
Take a deep breath in…
and then out.
When you're ready,
close your eyes
if you want to,
and picture
the entrance of Moordale.
As you wait
outside the school,
collect your energy
and scan your body.
Think about your head
and your beautiful brain,
and then just start
to feel the awareness
flow from the top
of your head
all the way down your body,
like a relaxing liquid
or a fluid.
Because everything
is fluid, isn't it?
Gender, sexuality…
icing sugar.
Feel it flowing
through your arms,
which will take longer
if they're unusually long,
like Otis Milburn.
And then,
right down to your feet
and the tip of your toes.
Take another deep breath
and begin to walk
towards the school entrance,
passing the wall
of Van Groff art
and the demolished toilets.
Walk slowly
towards the doors,
feeling the wind
on your face
and the smell of fresh paint
from a newly-graffitied
yoni.
As you open the doors,
you're greeted
by a sweetly smell.
This time,
it's freshly baked cupcakes,
courtesy of Aimee's Cakes.
Soft, warm and spongy.
Take in another deep breath
and check in with your body.
Are you tense anywhere?
If yes, offer that part
of your body, a cupcake,
placing that warmth there,
softening it with the cake.
As we move
further down the hall
towards the outside area,
take another deep breath
and scan your body,
focussing on
those parts of you
that feel a little stressed.
And like Otis and Eric,
or a good best friend would,
spend a moment there,
extending kind
and friendly awareness
towards that part
of your body,
without judgement.
Your body
is your best friend,
the Aimee to your Maeve.
Even if you're not
totally sure
why they adopted a goat,
allow that vision of Goat
to proceed
as you look outside.
And imagine it off its lead,
running around
the school grounds,
wise, free, fearless.
You're all of those things.
You're the goat.
So offer yourself
gratitude for that,
for getting yourself
through the hallway
and through this day.
When you're ready,
open your eyes
and come back
to wherever you are,
remembering your wisdom
and that it's OK to let go.